comment re confinement ou pas telle est
la grande question
selon un dernier sondage opinionway plus
de 70% des français s'y prépare mais du
côté du gouvernement
l'idée n'est pas encore arrêtée à
l'image du président du conseil
scientifique métronome souvent des
prises des décisions de l'exécutif
nous avons deux possibilités on attend
la fin de la semaine pour disposer des
résultats de la deuxième enquête flash
de santé publique france et des deux
semaines de recul pour évaluer l'impact
du couvre-feu à 18 heures seconde
possibilité au vu des premières données
qui montrent que le variant angles et
circule de manière plus importante qu'on
ne le pensait on anticipe pour ma part
je pense qu'on n'est pas dans l'extrême
urgence
on n'est pas à une semaine près une
dernière déclaration en une d'un journal
qui pose problème
d'autant que quelques heures auparavant
le président du conseil scientifique
déclaré qu'il y avait urgence face à un
virus diabolique un changement de temps
en moins de 48 heures pour une multi
mise au point je n'ai pas changé d'un
iota entre dimanche et aujourd'hui la
décision doit être prise entre la fin de
semaine et le milieu de la semaine
prochaine
on n'est pas à trois jours près ce n'est
pas de l'extrême urgence comme une
opération chirurgicale
cette décision est extrêmement lourde il
faut tout peser une prise de décision
tardive du gouvernement qui agace
l'opposition qui réclame plus de
discussions
ce que nous demandons depuis le début
c'est que ce soit les politiques qui
prennent les décisions et non pas un
conseil scientifique qui est seulement
là pour donner un avis
leur confinement serait un échec le
président de la république décide
vous qui êtes journaliste moi qui suis
député on ne sait rien de ce qui va être
annoncé mercredi
on est suspendu à notre poste de
télévision comme tous les citoyens quel
est le lieu des changes de débats aucun
1re confinement total aurait des
conséquences humaines très fortes
notamment chez les jeunes de plus en
plus en difficulté
la résilience des français est
formidable par ailleurs en cas de retour
à 1 re confinement strict la question se
posera d'un vote du parlement pour
l'autoriser ou non cacophonie au sein du
parlement mais aussi dans certaines
i comme à cabourg sans mère tristan
duval a informé lundi en ouverture du
conseil municipal car confinement de
cinq semaines allaient être annoncées
dès ce mercredi
information démentie sur les réseaux
sociaux par le préfet du calvados
tristan duval a présenté lui ses excuses
sur twitter précisant qu'il ne s'agit
que de rumeurs en cours tergiversations
ou pas ces dernières heures la ministre
chargé de l'industrie a confirmé qu' à
sa connaissance et à ce stade il n'y
avait pas raison de décider d'un
confinement